so let's use that right now here's a
question and here's the way it's being
stated this by the way the first line
here is often the clue for you that
tells you are you in degrees are you in
radians they will still keep on giving
you both so you have to remain bilingual
if you like that 2pi their signal to you
okay we're in radians land here's the
solution
here's the equation that we need to find
a solution for okay so let's think about
how much of this we can do just normally
right do we have the angle in mind that
gives us the exact value of 1/2 have a
look for signs sign of something gives
you a 1/2 have a look at the two
triangles which ones are gonna be sign
think about this sign is arm which ratio
of sides
sohcahtoa think think think think signed
sign opposite on hypotenuse opposite
hypotenuse this should be the opposite
and this should be the hypotenuse which
angle has one opposite it and two on the
hypotenuse have a look at that you train
was it's on this triangle which angle do
I want it's gonna be the 30 degrees or
PI on six okay get encouraged as much as
possible to start shifting your brain
over into radians land right so the base
angle that I would want for X is PI on 6
that's the base angle but I know there's
more than one solution to this right
said again this is the question that is
the question it's seven eight it's in
the exercise that she gave you so that
you know that you'd have to redo this
one okay so if that's the question I've
got a base angle an exact value but I
know there's another one how do I work
out where the other solution is think
back to this guy hmm
think big think it's been a while since
we looked at these we're looking its
side right sign and is this guy over
here is it hard so health is it positive
or is it negative it's positive right so
that tells you to remember that's why we
use this diagram which quadrants were
going to be in so all of them positive
here so I'm going to get one solution
already have Pilon six where's the other
positive solution gonna be it's over
here cuz what's the function that I'm
looking at its sign right so there's the
s4 side okay so I've got my first one
and now I've got my second one my other
solution will be not parent six but PI
takeaway pilot 6 PI takeaway oops
I'm already writing the answer PI
takeaway plan six that's my second
quadrant angle okay so I'm just gonna
simplify that off what is pi takeaway
pilot six pi takeaway PI on six this is
like one take away a six right it's
gonna be positive or negative it's
positive right because it's like this
what is bigger than a sixth right so
therefore my answer should be positive
when I subtract so I've got five PI on
six here and because this is still new
and uncomfortable I encourage you get
your calculator out make sure it's in
radians mode and pop both of these in
sine of this should give you half sine
of this if we've done it right you
should also give you a half it's going
to be pretty easy to get the wrong
answer early on because we're still
trying to do the conversions all that
kind of thing in our brain and it's been
a while since we've touched these kinds
of questions so you'll need to use that
so you've got a thing to rest on okay do
you want to do another example so we can
we get ourselves yep okay um I already
went at my iPad go oh I gave it to
that's right
I just gave way to figure out what else
do you you might by the way what a boot
up your laptop down because we were in
1484 we're going to continue but in the
meantime I'll pick one out from 14 a
that continues fine
that was seven a let's do seven me why
not
okay as that boots up you can have a
look with me okay so here's the question
you can boot that up silently while
still still paying attention so to have
a look this time I've got a different
function different value at the end okay
so let's think about this cause x equals
to negative 1/2 I'm just gonna forget
about that side for a minute just so I
can think about what value I should get
cos x equals 1/2 which of the exact
angles causes the adjacent on hypotenuse
which of the exact angles is gonna be
the one that gives me 1/2 PI / fig thick
it's gonna be this guy right because the
half that I'm getting is adjacent on
hypotenuse yeah said again Y is what - 1
yep so I'm going to come to the yet
that's the question
yep so I'm gonna come to that side in a
minute but I just want to think about
the value all of this see how every
single number here is positive all right
so that's why I'm just thinking about
the positive part so I know that my base
angle is gonna be what do we just say
pilot 3 because it's adjacent what
happened is you okay with that so let's
just I'm gonna write down PI on 3 over
here but then I know and this is where
my quadrants diagram comes in cosines
not supposed to be positive 1/2 it's
supposed to be negative 1/2 so I've got
to work out which quadrants do I belong
in have a look
I want cosine to be negative right is is
cosine positive negative here it's not
so I'm gonna leave that one is cosine
negative here it is because sine is the
only one that's positive that's the
whole point of the S right so this is
good is a cos gonna be negative here it
is and then lastly just for completeness
is it gonna be negative here and Sanur
that's why there's a C there okay so I'm
looking for second quadrant notes are
and a third quadrant answer and they're
going to look like this channel
why do we use this triangle yep
so we're thinking about first we're
trying to work out the exact value
that's appropriate right so I'm thinking
about a half and only one of these
triangles this one has a half in it if
there was a one on route 2 then I'd be
in the second triangle does that make
sense
cool let me fix this question and put it
back to what it was okay
so I know what my base angle is it spy
on three okay but I actually want to see
what does that look like in the
quadrants you just told me that's the
second the third ones okay so I'm gonna
write it like so it's PI take away our
base angle or it's what does it look
like in the third quadrant PI plus the
base angle right can we do this without
resorting to a calculator anything like
that
I think about this is one take away a
third what's one take away a third it's
two thirds but then there's PI's right
so it's two thirds other PI this is one
plus a third how many thirds is that 4
over 3 but there's a PI so I'll say for
play on three go ahead roll your
calculator out check it out and make
sure that we've actually got the right
one right put cause off make sure you're
in radians mode because otherwise you're
going to get all different answers but
it should give us negative 0.5 well then
your behalf to pay what your calculator
says can we get some confirmation
sorry how's a bit naughty
I didn't write X my bad did you get it
checks out both of them just yeah okay
well ones ones a good start do you guys
have a calculator yep
okay now gonna hit pause on you there
the reason why I showed you this at the
beginning even though I know some of
you're not up to it is some of you are
almost up to it so I didn't want to stop
you halfway
you're still in 14th a the questions
there are going to start looking at more
complicated versions of that but if I'm
going to leave this up on the board so
you can refer to it I hope you have it
there as well okay
which part there's a I've got a minus
sign here and a minus sign here do you
mean this one this is the question how
do I go over here so how do I get from
here to here is that the question
so I say cause X if it's negative 1/2
it's it's a it's a negative number okay
and this I'll actually confess this is
not my favorite way to explain it but
it's the way that doesn't rely on
graphing which we are getting to soon so
if I think about this ast see it's just
an acronym to help us remember in
different for different size angles the
different trig functions become positive
or negative positive or negative so the
a stands for every single trig function
sine cos and tan they're all positive in
here so pick an angle that's acute pick
me an angle any anger you like forty
okay go to your calculator you gave it
to me in degrees so you should pop your
calculator in degrees as well and just
try sine 40 degrees cos 40 degrees and
tan 40 degrees right and I didn't really
care about the value all I care about is
are they positive or negative right
how did you go I'm guessing that's about
point mmm
point six so like that point four ish
yep you get the idea right so do you see
how they're all positive so long as you
give me an acute angle you could give me
another acute angle
seventy or eighty one or whatever you
like so long as it's acute they're all
going to be positive that okay when I go
into obtuse angles over here right if
you're putting up to single into sine
cos and tan the only one that ends up
positive is sine so we write an S okay
so give me an obtuse angle anyone saying
you like 110 if you go ahead and you try
sine hundred ten cos 110 and ten a
hundred and ten okay when you go ahead
hopefully we'll find that sine is a
positive and then these guys I don't
know what their numbers will be but
they'll be negative right go ahead and
just check it a new calculator sign
hundred and ten are you in radians you
told me degrees so I mean we could put
this in radians if you like but you just
handed me a degree because we took more
comfortable with that this makes sense
so I'm like oh this is the one that's
positive when you go into the third
quadrant which one do you think is
positive just am signing cause of birth
negative and then lastly in the fourth
quadrant cause will be positive sign
will be negative Tanabe negative okay so
now keep that in mind that's what the
ast C is just help to design you to
remember and now let's come back here so
there's some angle you don't know what
it is okay but they tell you when you
take COS of that angle you get a
negative number out so you should be
able to rule out some of these places
right remember yeah no matter what you'd
put in there cos of that angle be
positive so it can't possibly be that
can't be one of those angles it's the
same deal here you try an angle between
270 and 360 or three point two and two
pi you always get something positive so
it can't possibly be one of those so
that's why
yeah causes negative here cuz it's also
negative does that make a little more
sense